genau österreich hat jetzt als erstes
land der welt die impfpflicht
beschlossen und entgegen aller aussagen
von lauterbach und söder wird die
impfpflicht auch in deutschland kommt es
nach antibes wird jetzt schon dafür
gebaut wir sehen jetzt schon wie kräftig
die werbetrommel gerührt wird und wie
auch die presse dem in ins gleiche horn
bläst wir sehen dass die vorbereitung
auf hochtouren laufen so hat die
bundesregierung zum beispiel auf ihrer
krone informations website das nein zu
impfpflicht heruntergenommen ich bin
ganz klar gegen eine impfpflicht warum
es gibt mehrere gründe zum einen
natürlich wird die jetzt schon gespalten
die gesellschaft weiter gespalten so
kann es nicht weitergehen parallel ist
es ein eingriff des staates in die
selbstbestimmung und ein verstoß gegen
das grundgesetz gegen die menschenwürde
und gegen die unversehrtheit des körpers
aus dem grund sollte man auf jeden fall
die impfpflicht nicht unterstützen das
würde auch bedeuten nach momentanen
status nach sechs bis zwölf monaten muss
man immer wieder zum impfen gehen bald
die wirksamkeit nachlässt und parallel
in frage wie soll das umgesetzt werden
kommt dann die polizei und sammelt die
menschen ein und bringt zum impfen vor
allem was es mit menschen die aus
gesundheitlichen gründen nicht geimpft
werden können werden die gekennzeichnet
werden die separiert da kommen gar nicht
schlimm mit bilder bei mir im kopf hoch
ich glaube er dass die politik hier in
sündenbock gefunden hat um von ihrer
inkompetenz von ihren historischen
versagen abzulenken und jetzt nicht
darauf hinweist zu sagen hier in den
städten wurden abgebaut oder personal
wurde eingespart und sitzen wir schon
wieder vor dem nächsten locker und fakt
ist nach der impfung ist vor der impfung
und nachdem london ist vor dem locker
und wer die freiheit aufgibt um
sicherheit zu gewinnen wird am ende
beides verlieren ein sehr schönes zitat
eines meiner lieblings zitate ich bin
natürlich auch definitiv gegen die
impfpflicht was ich aber sagen muss ist
ich finde es nicht so dramatisch werden
sie zwölfter impfen lassen als man
dachte also ich habe jetzt auch seit
meine booster impfung nächste woche und
freue mich auch darauf was ich aber
finde es wir dürfen menschen nicht zum
impfen zwingen absolut und deswegen bin
ich ganz klar fürs impfen aber gegen die
impfpflicht aber die impfpflicht bisher
schon längst da also ich halt letzte
woche erschüttern auch diese woche wir
schreiben immer viele zuschauer von 48
was mich sehr freut und zwei jahren
erzählt sie dürfen schon nicht meinen
arbeitsplatz warum war jetzt zweig
eingeführt wurde das heißt die
impfpflicht ist er längst da wir sind
noch nicht so weit dass menschen dazu
gezwungen werden die impfungen zu
bekommen was übrigens auch ein grobes
unrecht wäre an der freiheit aber wenn
arbeitnehmer arbeitgeber natürlich sagen
die arbeitnehmer darf jetzt nicht mehr
an seinen arbeitsplatz kommen das ist
existenzbedrohend dementsprechend weiß
gar nicht mehr warum über die
impfpflicht importieren wir haben sie
längst mich macht das sehr traurig und
ich muss übrigens sagen als kämpfte ich
würde lieber den locker und wieder haben
wo wir alle gleich sind als dass wir
jetzt geimpft und in eine
zwei-klassen-gesellschaft rasens machen
andere länder auch nicht und ich finde
es ganz ganz dramatisch also beim thema
locker und da muss ich ein x eintragen
die berliner weil glaube ich wir da in
diesem punkt extrem vorsichtig sein
müssen
rippel hat das gerade auch schon
angesprochen das glaube ich ein punkt
der der in dieser ganzen debatte viel zu
kurz kommt die frage am ende was kostet
uns eigentlich dieser lockt da und wir
gehen immer auf menschenleben was
absolut richtig ist weil ein
menschenleben natürlich erst einmal
unbezahlbar ist aber da hängt ja
trotzdem vieles andere dran denn wenn
ein mensch stirbt ist das ganz ganz
tragisch für den menschen für die
angehörigen aber wenn menschen
beispielsweise nicht arbeiten können
oder ihr geschäft aufgeben müssen pleite
gehen dann produziert das auch sehr sehr
viel leid nicht direkt den tod
möglicherweise aber anderes leid und am
ende ökonomen rechnen trotzdem alles in
kosten auf die frage was ist ein
menschenleben wert an was es aber dann
auch das leid das körperliche light eine
psychologische eine psychische krankheit
beispielsweise was sind das für kosten
das mag jetzt kalt klingen aber am ende
ist das ein weg um einfach mal zu
quantifizieren was sind die kosten des
einen weges was sind die des anderen weg
und wir gucken bisher immer nur auf die
kosten des weges menschen vor dem die
die zum teil auch sehr alt sind vor dem
tod zu retten wir gucken aber nicht auf
die kosten beispielsweise von
schulschließungen ja was sind das für
kosten die entstehen bei kindern nicht
das richtige lernen von
ladenschließungen von hotel schließung
von restaurant schließung nicht nur der
ökonomische schaden aber auch dann der
nächste schaden bei den menschen die
pleite gehen beispielsweise oder nicht
mehr arbeiten können dieses
kostenverhältnis das haben wir überhaupt
nicht im blick wir gucken nur auf die
einen kosten- und ich plädiere dafür
müssen die anderen kosten unbedingt
stärker berücksichtigen denn ich glaube
dann kommen wir in vielerlei abwägung
auch zu einem anderen ergebnis und die
aufgabe sicherlich dazu ist das jetzt
ein plädoyer für die impfpflicht das ist
erstmal offenes plädoyer beim thema
impfpflicht könnte ich noch viel viel
sagen ich glaube ja dass wir darüber
nachdenken müssen wie man personen die
externe kosten erzeugen das ist auch
wieder sehr technisch aber die
andere menschen in ihrem leben in
irgendeiner art und weise
beeinträchtigen könnten wie man die an
kosten die entstehen beteiligt wir
machen das plastisch gesagt einmal beim
thema umwelt co2 wenn eine fabrik zu
viel dreck ausstößt dann belastet dass
die umwelt belastet die menschen drum
herum wohnen also was muss passieren
fabrik muss dafür bezahlen unsere co2
abgabe und ich glaube man muss schon mal
gucken dass man eine gesellschaft nicht
mit zu vielen kosten belastet die dann
die allgemeinheit tragen muss wenn man
sie selbst verursacht sondern man sollte
sich immer in gewisser weise daran
beteiligen ja ich finde also ich bin
auch kein befürworter der impfpflicht
halte das für weiß auch gar nicht wie
man es am ende des tages wirklich
verächtlich uns umsetzen soll ich glaube
auch dass verfassungsrechtliche in
deutschland nicht funktioniert
wir haben diese debatte bei der masern
erkrankung bei der masernimpfung gehabt
da war es für einen bestimmten
personenkreis nach ewig langen
studienzeiten 20 vorher aber das war
auch mit einem mit einem langzeit
studien dies zu masern impfstoff gibt wo
es nur für bestimmte gruppen bis zum
thema kita und schule wichtig war und
für das personal dort vorher also es war
eine kleine gruppe dass deswegen kann
ich mir vorstellen dass man das in der
pflege umgesetzt bekommt weil man sagt
da ist das verhältnis
der schutzbedürftigen der volatilität
der der betroffenen person so groß dass
man das der macht an sich glaube ich
dass man so nicht umsetzt mich stört
daran auch ich wär ja ehrenamtlich noch
präsident vom deutschen roten kreuz in
berlin und wir haben mobile teams auch
draußen und ich sehe in den letzten
wochen vor dem don juan center das ist
ein vietnamesischer großmarkt hier in
berlin wo wir 50.000 impfungen insgesamt
gehabt in den mobilen zentren davon
15.000 erstimpfungen den letzten drei
wochen das ist eine gehörige zahl von
menschen die wir noch erreicht haben
ohne druck und drangsalierung sondern
weil wir am richtigen ort waren druck
und verlieren schon da die zweijährige
lungen restaurants gibt selbst schon
länger als zwei mal das war aber noch
davor das war noch da vor drei wochen
gab es schon ja ja aber das als wir
angefangen haben mit den mobilen teams
und als sie als die menschen dahin kamen
das war noch davor und wenn man sie
gefragt hat und ich habe mit einigen von
denen gesprochen war das nicht weil
jetzt in ihrem restaurant zweig oder sie
zweig einführen wollen sondern es war
weil sie gar keinen zugang hatten sie
haben kein niedergelassener arzt sie
wandeln kann im zentrum wir haben dann
auch muttersprachliche das personal dort
eingestellt wo auch gleich von angesicht
zu angesicht gesehen wurde hier kann ich
hingehen hier kann ich auch eine frage
stellen ohne dass sich eine
sprachbarriere habe und ich glaube wir
haben auch viele menschen noch nicht
erreicht das ist mag möglicherweise
in manchen ländlichen regionen
komplizierter sein aber ich glaube den
städten haben wir noch nicht alle
personen erreicht die wir erreichen
können und ich teile die einschätzung
die werbung für das impfen und der aber
sprechen hat aber klar aussagen ganz
klar auch in milieus mit großem hohen
migrationshintergrund beispielsweise
gibt es weiterhin ein problem und das
hat auch die bundesregierung
beispielsweise haben die landesregierung
bisher nicht hinbekommen in diesem
bereich einzuwirken oder gibt es da eine
generelle barriere würde wir haben das
ja bei der bei masern impfung und so
gesehen da haben wir ja wir haben in
berlin übrigens bei den masernpartys
ehren problem im kleinen büro im
bildungsbürgertum der der grünen
innenstadt wähler am helmholtzplatz und
und in der innenstadt und bei den
muslimischen berlinerinnen und berlinern
ist es so dass dort die imame dafür
predigen zu impfen und die impfquote ist
enorm hoch und dann in den schulen in
neukölln das problem nicht so stark wie
im prenzlauer berg also ich würde es
nicht immer am migrationshintergrund
festmachen aber hier beim thema irgendwo
hingegen chromit 19 sieht man schon das
problem ist der zugang ist nicht so
einfach vorhanden und es gibt einige
fragen auch übrigens in der community
der der deutschen aus russland die sagen
wir würden uns gerne impfen lassen aber
wir haben höheres vertrauen den sputnik
wir möchten gerne dass das hier
zugelassen wird und wir haben uns
teilweise auch im ausland impfen lassen
dass man dass man ernst nehmen muss und
dann gucken muss dass man das besser
hinkriegt aber die eigentliche frage ist
sind wir bereit für die 13 die sich
nicht helfen lassen denn lockdown zu
haben mit all den folgen die wir bei
kindern und jugendlichen kommen gleich
zu zum beispiel in der arche und da sage
ich diesen preis bin ich eigentlich
nicht